okay
[Music]
Christian
s
how are you
[Music]
alive
foreign
[Music]
before
Christmas
[Music]
thank you
welcome back
[Music]
I tried the whole time
sorry if I messed up your idea
I wrote it down
testing
well I guess I didn't realize church was
starting
I was just talking to friends
that was my fault friend not friend
welcome everyone I see a couple of new
faces but I also haven't been here for a
little bit so that's on me but my name's
Miriam for the people that I haven't met
uh nice to meet you all so got a couple
of announcements for you all
um first and foremost first and foremost
no service next Sunday so I think twice
a year they do no service on a Sunday to
give the volunteers a break and it's
Memorial Day weekend so you can go on a
little vacay with your family or just
sit at home and watch Netflix probably
what I will do but no one will be here
next Sunday so we will be back two
Sundays from now and then uh two Sundays
from now is senior Sunday June 4th so
we're going to be honoring our graduates
that Sunday
yay
ah not you
um
so if you have a high school graduate
please let us know by filling out a card
on the tiny table here to the back or
through those doors
um so that we can honor your senior
um also on that same note we are hosting
a booth or a table at the pride festival
on June 3rd on Saturday the booth is
indoors so no excuses there I already
signed up so if you are interested in
signing up you can fill out one of those
cards as well it's the same card for
everything just in the comments say that
you're interested in volunteering for
the booth or if you have any questions
you can talk to Marissa she is back
there for anyone that doesn't know her
she's raising her hand
um yeah go to her not me I don't know
anything else other than that so uh yeah
that's all that I have for you so I'm
gonna lead us in a quick little prayer
before we get started
thank you God I want to thank you for
um everyone that's here tonight everyone
that was able to get here safely
um especially with the storms going on
this past week I thank you for new faces
new friends old faces old friends and
the community that we have here I pray
that if anyone is new or um struggling
or just needs a friend that they feel
comfortable in coming and talking to
someone in this open space and that
they're able to be themselves and feel
at home because the table is a home for
many and that's what we want to be for
everyone I pray that you speak through
Brett through the sermon tonight and I
pray that you give him words of wisdom
as he speaks Your Truth over us and I
pray for the worship team as they lead
us in worship as well it's in Jesus name
I pray amen
man thank you
would you guys stand with us
called heavy we introduced it a couple
weeks ago and it just seemed to resonate
I think especially right now with just
the climate of our world and our
individual like especially like this
country and the Never Stop hamster wheel
that we all are on especially at this
time of year when coming to the ends of
school years and all the things
um I just feel like we need somebody to
be like hey
breathe for a second
take a minute you know let go of some of
the things that you're carrying and
sometimes that doesn't mean like we can
practically offload all of our tasks
that we have in front of us but to take
a second to Center our mind and our
heart and remember that Jesus doesn't
put on things that are heavy he invites
us into Freedom so let's go there
together let's enjoy the freedom and you
guys are fully 100 welcome and a part of
this band right here I just want to
invite you if you didn't know you are an
extension it doesn't end at the end of
this stage this is an all play so this
is this is worship and what worship is
is a community coming together centering
around truths that we believe
um you see in the life of Jesus in the
life of our community so please enter in
with us feel 100 welcome here all right
Jesse and well actually noelle's Gonna
Get Us started on drums so we're gonna
enjoy every Sunday that we have with
Noel before she's gone
to college so
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're lost and lonely go and figure
out why
take a trip to your dark side go on and
have a good cry
cause we're all lonely
and we're all lonely together
I want to see your sadness
I want to share your sins I want to
bleed your blood
I want to be lit
in don't you judge
don't we all just wanna be together
[Music]
leave
what's heavy behind
[Music]
leave
what's heavy
once heavy behind
your face is down to take a look around
but do your fingers
[Music]
the day
did you lose
are you sad because you did a bad thing
[Music]
what's heavy behind me
was Heavy
[Music]
what's heavy behind
oh
foreign
[Music]
fearful brother are you feeling fearful
sister
only way to lose that fearful feeling
replace it with love that's healing
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful sisters
[Music]
leave what's happening
what's heavy behind
what's heavy
[Music]
me
what's heavy behind
awesome all right kiddos y'all are
dismissed to your classrooms we have
preschoolers over here or not just
preschoolers also kindergarten I think
and then our schoolers over here in this
room
thank you kids ministry people
you know
you know nursery workers in the back
thank you so much
[Music]
we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people so if this is your
first time here it's just an opportunity
for us as a community to share the
things that we're carrying on our heart
so we're going to read this prayer
together and then leave some space for
us to say names or situations that we're
carrying if you're online please feel
free to leave those in the comments and
we can share those with the room
and then we will close out prayer
together again
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
foreign
[Music]
s that we have spoken aloud and for
those that we have kept in our hearts we
pray to you that they may have light and
life
healing and Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run the fountain I drink from oh
he is
[Music]
my song
you are good
good oh
good
[Music]
oh you are good
oh
let the king of my heart be the wind
inside myself
the anchor in my waves oh he is
[Music]
let the king of my heart be the inside
myself
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
and you're never gonna let Never Gonna
Let Me Down
You're Never Gonna Let Never Gonna Let
Me Down
You're Never Gonna
[Music]
bet you're never gonna let me down
you're never gonna let you know you're
gonna let me down
you're never gonna laugh Never Gonna Let
Me Down
[Music]
you're never gonna let
down
you're never gonna let You're Never
Gonna Let Me Down
[Music]
foreign
to me
God is
[Music]
holding on
God is
[Music]
God
take my life and let it be consecrated
[Music]
my days
Jesus
days
let them flow in ceaseless
please
take my hands
[Music]
beautiful
for these
thank you
take my voice
always
only
for my king
Take My Eyes
let's sing take my will
[Music]
take my will and make it thine
it shall be no longer mine
take my heart
it is
[Music]
take my love my Lord I pour
add thy feed its Treasures
take myself
and I will be ever
only
oh for thee
the
ever only
[Music]
God we give you ourselves
and I don't take that as a light
statement because
that involves
letting go that involves
surrender
foreign
[Music]
but I want you to be the one directing
our steps
for you to be the one leading and
guiding us into love
into who you created us to be
you God the one who knit us together
would we return home to you
would we open our hands
and let you show us a better way
[Music]
God would we give our words over to you
would we learn when to be quiet
[Music]
to close our mouths
and when to speak
[Music]
would we know when to share
would we know how to forgive
[Music]
how to let go of bitterness and pain and
resentment that we're carrying
God would you guide us into your freedom
help us to let go of what's heavy let go
of the sin Let Go of the bondage
or the pain
move into light
move into Grace
move into your transformational work in
our hearts
would we be a whole people
a whole community
[Music]
would we be holy yours
thank you for this time together thank
you for each person in this room God
speak to us God
we want to know your heart
[Music]
in your name we pray amen
do you guys turn to the people sitting
around you welcomed them make them feel
at home and then Brett will get us
started on our message
beautiful
foreign
Grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all um
welcome to the table and that welcome
includes everyone uh but that also
includes those joining us online love
y'all lots and um and anyone here who is
new thank you for for being with us and
I just I know what a um just kind of in
at times it's different for different
people kind of it can be intimidating it
can be just downright scary to come into
a new community and it's just like oh
gosh
don't know these people and uh I hope
you feel a sense of welcome I do I hope
you um I hope you feel that because we
really are glad that you're here
um so you've you've come at a good time
uh you all because we are into uh this
is part seven we're almost at the end I
think um I see we're off next week uh
and then June 4th will be our last uh
Sunday in the series and so we've been
in this series titled Easter time this
is not the end uh for many of us we grew
up like where Easter was a one day thing
but for much of the broader Church
Easter is actually an entire season so
we've been kind of participating in that
in that season I love that um that sense
of connectedness to the broader Church
there's ways in which the table is
unique and um Not always completely in
lockstep with the broader Church
um and I'll actually get into some of
that in in two weeks talking about unity
and such
um but in other ways I love when we can
be like hey on this we agree
you know and Christ is resurrected and
that's a beautiful beautiful thing and a
point of unity for us so really what
this Series has been about is not just
celebrating Jesus like oh good you know
he's risen hooray for Jesus but
um looking at the more God has for us
the the Resurrection Life that we all
are invited into
um that's really the the heart of this
series so we've been kind of unpacking
what does that mean uh to live into that
so with that in mind the title of my
message specific to tonight is drawn and
reformed drawn and reformed if you were
with us last week you know then the
title and message last week was drawn
and we looked at
um this short passage where Jesus says
this John 14 verse 15. and he says this
if you love me
keep my commands
if you love me keep my commands and so
what we touched on last week was that
when we hear that I don't know about all
of you but at least where my mind went
and based on feedback I got it's unlike
many of you where our minds tend to go
is to that second part keep my commands
and how we aren't maybe always doing so
well at that
and then the response to that kind of
perceived like failure or struggle is to
um kind of double down on the keeping
right um to kind of a a certain mode of
like striving
and uh that can be it's almost it
becomes a very anxious way of being
Christian
and so what we touched on last week was
like What if maybe that's not such a
good reading
of that passage in other words the idea
of like double down on the effort and
the discipline and then eventually a
love for Jesus Will Follow You know but
instead what if we reversed it um we had
a a quote this is from Dallas Willard
and he says this what if the source of
the keeping is the loving
right so the the love what if we
um cultivate love
and then suddenly the keeping of The
Commandments follows the there's a
number of um quotes that kind of fed
into this so um you know if you were
here last week you'll recognize some of
these James K Smith the Theologian
Christian philosopher he put it this way
he said we aren't really motivated by
abstract ideas
or pushed by rules and duties
instead some panoramic Tableau that
means like Vision or story of what looks
like flourishing has an alluring power
that attracts
right and you can you can kind of feel
there like there's a difference between
um being guilt-tripped into something
and being drawn by Beauty and love right
can you kind of feel the difference in
that
um Even in our human relationships that
can be very true like it's amazing like
when we really love someone the the
things we'll go through to express that
love like it's great you know I mean
like we'll just we can look like the
most committed disciplined person
um and vice versa if we really aren't
drawn to someone like just to be nice
can be like okay I can do this you know
it can really take some some push
through so that's kind of the question
we're asking is what would it look like
to really be drawn by Love and Desire
instead of kind of just trying to double
down on our efforts another quote that
was instructive last week was uh from
the French writer Antoine dusson
I've been working on that for two weeks
now
I think that was pretty good right
pretty good fridge I mean not bad
probably a French person would be like
you still sound like a Texan but
um but he said this if you want to build
a ship
Don't drum up people to collect wood
don't assign them tasks and work but
rather teach them to long for the
endless immensity of the sea that's
beautiful isn't it like in the way we
translated that is if you um maybe say
want to build a church Community if you
want folks to
um like to obey the commands like to
follow Christ and live
um with that kind of commitment well
then don't like guilt-trip folks and
don't like force them into you better be
here every Sunday if you're not you're
gonna get an angry text you know we're
like no don't do that or don't even like
scare people into religious belief but
with threats of hell and Damnation and
you know Eternal conscious torment all
that like don't go that road instead do
what teach them to long for the endless
immensity of the God who is love like
just imagine a community of people uh
and not just our church but like a
broader church that loved God like long
for the endless immensity of Christ
father son the spirit The God Who is
love like imagine the the transformation
that that would work in our hearts and
Minds right and outwardly
um that would it might look like oh wow
so disciplined you know like really
they're really faithful but it's you can
see there where the right it's about the
motivation the desire what's what's
drawing us so that's kind of where we
were last week so where I wanted to go
is kind of jump from that because I I
think in ways that we kind of touched on
it in a few places where I could have
left you last week is wondering okay
awesome but how like how do I do be you
know tonight you find yourself like oh
I'd love to long for the immensity of
the God who is love you know or as we've
been in this whole series been talking
about you know Resurrection Life Union
with God and that can all start to sound
very lofty and sort of like yeah awesome
you know but
um how like how do I cultivate that
um so that's kind of where we're going
in the message tonight and where I
wanted to start was by talking about
what does it feel like when you're on
the right track
if I had to sum it up in just one word
it would be the word peace
not being the smartest person in the
room
not even the smartest Bible person in
the room
but a deep inner peace
like that's when you know
oh my gosh
something is happening in my heart in my
mind
like this situation would have freaked
me out and yet all of a sudden
I trust
God is with me
I don't have to be so afraid
right that's that's when you know
um you're on the right track there's
peace but perhaps that's too reductive I
mean we could talk about other you know
love and other things but I'll just go
with that word tonight like peace and
and clearly in that I'm talking about
um a piece that comes from the spirit of
God within it I don't mean just an
external peace like when everything in
your life finally lines up and
everyone's getting along and all of your
relationships are finally perfect and
you have peace then you know it's
working no that's um not in this world
not in this life you're waiting for
external circumstances like oh you're
gonna be waiting a while uh it's got to
be
it's got to be right here that's how you
know there's a beautiful passage from
Philippians 4 6 and 7. the Apostle Paul
writes do not be anxious about anything
but rather in every situation by prayer
and petition with Thanksgiving present
your request to God verse 7 in the peace
of God
the peace of God which transcends all
understanding meaning you might be quite
surprised at its presence
right like it's not like oh yeah this
makes sense you know I'm relaxed on
vacation I have such peace I'm not
surprised you know no this is one of
those moments where it's like oh my gosh
I can't believe it and yet even in the
midst of maybe the pain and the
heartache
it's like you know what
I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay God is with me God
loves me I'm okay I'm okay
that's like that's a powerful moment and
the peace of God which transcends all
understanding it will guard your heart
your hearts and your minds in Christ
Jesus
you know when I think of folks who've
journeyed a long time with God
and I think of who they become it's that
verse
there's a deep and abiding peace in them
and can you see why it would make sense
that if you cultivate
That Kind of Love and Desire and peace
that the keeping of The Commandments
might follow
can you kind of start to see the see the
connection
I might kind of reverse to put it in the
negative
um I might say it like this if that's
because it's our anxiety
our insecurity our fear that lead us
into our most reactionary moments and to
put it mildly our most regrettable
decisions ever had a regrettable
decision that's a little formal and
tamed you know it's like oh my gosh have
I lost my mind what was I thinking you
know we've all had those moments like oh
my
um and what was it that took us there
right it was our insecurities our
anxieties our fears it's that mode and
that's where you can see where I'm
trying to kind of get us to think
differently that it's not just a matter
of like you know sure be in in a glass
case of emotion and you know like kind
of freaking out and then just discipline
yourself
you know I mean like ah something in
that's off like no I think we've got to
start to go to the root of it's about
our loves and our longings and our
desires and and finding that that deep
deep Peace So Okay so this leads us the
question
um how do we start to do that and
um I think this is a really interesting
question because where the church has
generally gone
um and I think this is because in in
ways we often the church doesn't realize
how the culture the broader culture kind
of gets in to our own ways of thinking
um and we change and shift through the
centuries without even realizing what's
happening and if you think back on like
Western culture the last say three four
hundred years sorry I'm getting a little
nerdy don't worry the whole message
won't be like this but if you think of
the the last few hundred years it was
what's known as the the age of the
Enlightenment
um it was the you know the rise of
science today we just take science you
know the scientific method and all that
just completely for granted um but that
was you know sort of a newish thing and
it really emphasized that this age of
the Enlightenment emphasized
um it was really a view of the human
being as a thinking thing you know like
that's what you are you're like a
thinker and so the idea was
do you want to change do you want to
transform
well let me get you
the right information
here I've got books for you
you know I mean here I've got a podcast
for you yep it's taking this information
or go get that degree or whatever you
know and then
you will be transformed and changed
right it really we had this sort of um
we might put it is a very top-down view
of what transformation looks like from
the head down
right start with the prefrontal cortex
get the right information
and the rest of you know the body the
feelings the emotions all that will fall
into place
um can you see where this kind of made
its way into the church
um and just to be clear I'm not trying
to be anti-intellectual uh I mean for
anyone who knows me in my sermons I
don't think that's anything I've ever
been accused of you know like he just
hates the life of the mind you know now
I'm like Enneagram five intj
Myers-Briggs oh my gosh I'm like Mr
think it all through you know I'm I'm a
nerd um so I don't want to completely
throw that out
but you can see where in the church we
really got hooked into this in a way
where
um we said okay do you want to change
well
um study
you know what I mean like study so the
whole kind of like culture of the of
church is often centered around will go
to Bible studies
um go to Sunday school
um we'll do kind of you know expository
sermons like unpacking the Logics of
each verse and getting into every adverb
and pronoun and you know I mean like it
was sort of or even better like learn
the Greek learn the Hebrew get in the
original language if you do that and you
get like if you really understood the
text
then everything in your life would be
different you'd be radically transformed
and you would keep the commands right
like maybe we didn't literally put it
quite like that but something like that
has been
kind of operating
um
and again I'm not saying Bible study or
anything's wrong what this is um I've
drawn on some like already quoted him
James K Smith has really helped me think
this through and he said
um the problem with that is it's not a
very good view of the human being
um we actually aren't thinking things
first and foremost in fact even
Neuroscience has kind of proved this out
we are um we're feelers
we are we are emotional creatures like
all the way down we mostly do what we
feel like doing and then use our brains
to rationalize and justify whatever we
wanted to do in the first place
you know what I mean like this is
actually who we are in other words it's
a as we touched on this last week it's a
it's about desire
it's about love
and this is why if you want like folks
to
um follow Christ and like really follow
him don't just like cram more Bible
verses in I mean
like teach them too long
to Long
for transformation
teach them to hunger for the Living God
make them long for not not just ideas
about God but
and we got even a little bit of that
um tonight
as we sang which we'll get into actually
later in the message touching on some of
that it's it's a powerful
thing did not to be underestimated so
James K Smith
um he talks about something he calls him
cultural liturgies he says I think this
is how we actually change and transform
we catch like a vision of flourishing a
vision of the good life a vision and
ideal a dream like yes that's where I
want to go that's who I want to be in a
Christian context right it's like oh I
want to be like Jesus I want that peace
Pastor Brett was talking about that
piece yes that sounds good like I want
more of that so we start to catch a
vision for it and then the question is
though how how do we change and
transform it's what Smith he calls it a
cultural liturgy I like this word I know
it's a little strange liturgy kind of
comes from the Christian tradition
everything we've been doing tonight is a
liturgy so for example Miriam got up at
the beginning she's like hello welcome
to you all she gives some announcements
then she prayed and then we handed off
to worship when he sang a song We
dismiss the kids and then uh did the
prayers of the people and went back to
music right that's the the liturgy the
these kind of um repetitive uh elements
of worship right so what James K Smith
points out is he says what if liturgy
isn't just something we do on Sundays
what if like our whole life is full of
these little liturgies these like
repetitive ways
um these things that for these acts and
practices that form our hearts that aim
our desires here's his definition he
says cultural liturgies are repetitive
practices that teach us who we are right
identity
and aim our hearts in love in a certain
direction I might add to that all before
we ever even think about it
that's the key this is why I say it's
not so much top head down but body up
right just like I even will have folks
who like maybe come to the table and
they're like oh my gosh I know I need to
transform I need transformation I need
like a new
image of God my image of God has been
like judgment and super harsh and it's
no wonder I'm kind of like hesitant to
pursue God because it sounds kind of
mean you know and like I know I need
this transformation like how do I do it
and here's the key and it's not
necessarily that you have to like get
all the right ideas like well just read
a book of the truth you know about read
a book about the God who is love you
know
um I would say be here
in what happens it just seeps into you
right it's like through maybe that
sounds creepy I don't know but it's just
it's true right it's sort of it's not
just from the the top head down it's
from like the body by it's through our
bodies we just engage these things in
practices in a moment I'll get to um
some like more Christian liturgies is
really where I want to go but I'm going
to start with a few cultural liturgies
that's what I think is cool is we can
really start to think about like our
whole life as this process of formation
um for good and for ill for example how
about the cultural liturgy we touched on
YouTube last week
um how about the cultural Liturgy of
Twitter
like have you ever thought of when you
sign up for Twitter it's not just some
arbitrary decision to like am I going to
download an app or not
um it is a decision about whether you
are going to enter a community of
practice and formation
maybe I sound completely insane you're
like no I just get on there for the
funny memes you know I mean or whatever
um but I think I think most of us like
in essence it's not just that well the
way Smith puts it is it's not simply
that we do things they do things to us
whatever we do does things to us
and you get there on Twitter and the the
technology the algorithm and the people
the community does what
it's not just that you influence them
it's 2A right
they shape you
it guides your heart it trains you
to think in certain ways to be in
certain ways of course I'm picking on
Twitter this is true for any social
media app right keyword on social that's
the like that Dimension that that just
it just happens
um there's a few others like oh what
about the um this one I don't know this
maybe makes us uncomfortable but the
Pledge of Allegiance
that's a powerful cultural liturgy right
um there and the Hand of the heart and
and the repetition is key we often
really downplay even often in church
people like why do we do like the same
things over and over
because it works
I mean right this is what people have
figured out like you want to really get
something into someone do the prayer of
the people every single week and it's
just like gets in you know what I mean I
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United I still remember it I mean it's
that was like in third grade I guess and
you know I started homeschooling at
fourth grade so I did this for like
three years it's in me
you know what I mean and like people
stand up and I'm like yep I don't know
it's just it's like in my body can you
see where it's a bodily thing like no
one even sort of intellectually
explained now here's why we do this and
here's why it's important you should
read a book on the Pledge of Allegiance
and you know no no
you just do it
and you like learn
you know what I mean you just take it in
um and by the way I'm completely open
Twitter Pledge of Allegiance all these
I'm very open to people's thoughts as to
the good the bad you know I mean like
I'm not necessarily naming all these
like this is a complete and unmitigated
evil you know that's not my point I just
want us to start thinking about what is
forming you
right because it because you're being
formed being discipled every week right
I'm sorry if I sound angry I'm not I'm
just intense I'm really into that I like
this stuff
um or what about a frat house initiation
go to college and you have that for you
know what I mean and it's like you're
brought into the Brotherhood this the or
would be sorority for The Sisterhood you
know I mean and there's like a whole
thing to it
um birthday parties uh family meals
that's kind of interesting one you
gather on the table and have this moment
you know I mean and and that can be kind
of you know is that forming Us in good
ways or negative ways I know that this
kind of brings in maybe another Liturgy
of the smartphone which has certainly
made its way think of the smart what a
powerful we kind of combine often the
Liturgy of the family meal with the
smartphone not a picture of a modern
family everyone's sitting around the
table but looking like you know I mean
or maybe it's left hands they can eat if
they're right-handed you know I mean
just
like this is right you can see like
what's even um at its best I say that
family lots of powerful like there's the
game like hey how are you you know I
mean who remember who you are remember
who we are as a family you know I mean
there's something powerful in that um
coming back to the smartphone though
that that trains us
you know those every time that thing
dings you know we're gonna jump and like
oh I gotta respond I gotta do something
you know I mean it's sort of it almost
teaches us like hey are you bored that's
bad
you know you should never be bored right
this is It's again can you see where
these things are training us
um forming us so in essence here's kind
of what I'm driving at if you want to be
reformed right you want to to live into
the god whose love and join that Union
and have that peace if you want to be
reformed pay attention to the cultural
liturgies that are either deforming or
reforming your heart your mind your
desires so what are some Christian
liturgies I'm going to give you just a
few
um I'll give you three tonight and the
first one all these are kind of retro so
I'm not trying to be anything fancy um
the first Christian liturgy the Liturgy
of daily Stillness silent prayer and
scripture
I think there's nothing more profound
maybe like in essence I'm making an
argument that um I think we all need to
ReDiscover a quiet time
uh I don't know if you ever an
Evangelical in the 90s you heard of
quiet times it was basically like
devotional time you would you know have
some prayer in scripture and you know
but I just wonder if in an age of
constant activity and Buzz and go go go
go go go go if there's something so
powerful about like slipping off to your
room or a closet
and just being
quiet
like even just being with yourself for a
minute
and then starting to direct your
thoughts to God reading a scripture and
not just studying it
you know like what is the participle in
the Greek of this for you know but like
okay I mean if you want to do that
that's cool
but like let the beauty sink into you
let the message form you boy even just
10 minutes a day like that could be
seriously that's a powerful liturgical
act and again the repetition and
consistency is key to it you do it like
once a year you know but like this kind
of daily routine and it just gets into
your bones
um second would be the Liturgy of weekly
worship the Liturgy of weekly worship
Hebrews 10 24 and 25 says let us
consider how we may spur one another on
toward love and Good Deeds not giving up
meeting together as some are in the
habit of doing I was as I've kind of
already alluded to there's I think
elements of church and worship
um that this um it just it becomes a
kind of powerful act for us and
um again when it comes to our
Reformation in Christ repetition and
consistency are vitally important
there's just something about coming here
you walk through those doors and there's
like the hugs and the handshakes and you
come in
and there's the prayers and of course
the message in a moment we'll talk more
about the singing and the prayers of the
people and the benediction which I love
every week you are a child of God you
know I mean it's this and and what
happens again the repetition is so key
because it's from the body up you know
it's it's not always trying to like
convince you intellectually it's simply
reminding you of who you are you are a
child of God loved right and that
message it just comes to us again and
again and again and again and it forms
us
um third and finally the Liturgy of song
the book of Ephesians 5 19 speaking to
one another with Psalms hymns and songs
from the spirit sing and make music from
your heart to the Lord I think there's
something really insightful or not
insightful there's something really
powerful about music partly because it
does bypass the prefrontal cortex you
know I mean this part where we're like
always analyzing everything we are so in
our heads all the time
and so there's just something about
music the way like it just goes right
for your gut you know what I mean like
it goes right for your feelings
and emotions and it just moves you and
and it just speaks I mean I think maybe
you could feel some of what I was
feeling as we worshiped earlier
and
um just
to worship God to re-center on God
again this cultivates desire it aims and
directs our desire
and I think sometimes we can feel a
little bit um well there's all sorts of
there's been like worship wars in the
past but how you should do worship and
stuff um kind of in light of what I said
earlier uh about
um the Enlightenment and we got there
was a season in church history where we
were really into like very intellectual
songs you know like all the theology
just trying to like teach Systematic
Theology through the music and I I think
that could be maybe Tastefully or could
be done I'm not saying like let's make
this as thin soup as possible that's not
my point
um but in light of all I've been sharing
I think we've been maybe more wary of
emotion in the church and emotion in
music than we should have been it's
funny how we'll go to the concert and
just be like yes I mean get we will give
ourselves over to the music
you know I mean into its formative power
but then in church we're kind of like oh
gosh what's going on
you know what I mean oh we're singing I
don't know if I sing good you know I
mean or or we're intellectually
analyzing the Theology of the song you
know does that make sense like we're
kind of still lost in our heads and I
think this is some of what we have to
learn to do is like
Let It Go
give yourself to the music give yourself
to the Rhythm trust the lyrics and that
they're going to direct your heart and
mind towards the God who is love so I
guess in the end I think I'm making an
argument I think we need um more mushy
worship songs sometimes people talk
about like oh I don't like that song
that's a Jesus Is My Boyfriend song
um and I'm actually I'm a I'm a huge fan
of Jesus is my boyfriend's songs
um and I'm really not joking again
because of all this right like it's
funny how sometimes the most Progressive
of Christians who are like dude what we
need to throw a little theology like
they're like we need an incarnational
theology man like a a bodily in fleshed
you know feeling Christian that's what
we need man and you're like okay let's
sing this mushy worship song and they're
like what that's a Jesus is my
boyfriend's song I don't do those you
know it's like well can you see the
disconnect like no no that's kind of
exactly what we should be doing right
because again we're cultivating that
love
um for Jesus Christ and aiming our
desire
so in in conclusion
um I think this is uh this is what it's
going to take Church
um I think we have to start paying
attention to the liturgical acts that we
engage and
um
My Hope Is that those things will just
begin to form Us in powerful powerful
ways in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we come to the table of the Lord
today
as we take in the body of Christ in the
breath and the blood of Christ in the
wine
this itself
becomes a very powerful formative moment
and so what I encourage you to do is
again not just intellectually try to
figure it all out
but instead recognize that Christ has
promised to be present
through the Holy Spirit
to you
through these elements when we take in
the bread we take in the wine like we
take in Christ it's a moment of
communion connection
and it's a moment of Eucharist which
means Thanksgiving so that's the the
heart posture I invite you forward
tonight with that way we're going to do
this is we'll start kind of with the
front rows and we'll just work our way
back we practice what's called an Open
Table meaning if you're here tonight and
you want to participate then you are
totally free to do that no one's like
checking your theological credentials or
something or your church membership or
denominational affiliation
um just if you're here tonight you want
to connect with the Risen Christ then
you're free to do that the red cups are
wine and the white cups are grape juice
so you've been warned and
um
and then finally you can just partake of
the elements whenever you'd like no one
will like lead you through the exact
moment of you know how do I take it you
can do it immediately you can return to
your seat and take it there however
you'd like so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
come you who have much faith and you who
have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet
him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
you guys would like to stand with us I
invite you to do that we are going to
close out with a song
oh Jesus is my boyfriend's song
[Music]
um I definitely grew up in Evangelical
cares Mania and felt the need at one
point in my life to kind of Swing the
pendulum the other direction with
worship
um but then I'll just fast forward
yesterday I sat in a room with some good
friends and we sang the song Draw Me
Close to You and I don't know how many
of you guys either grew up or have sung
that song at some point in your life
it's like a Hallmark Jesus is my
boyfriend's song and you guys I can't
tell you like the medicine that it was
for my soul to sink into that music and
just like Brett was saying allow the
music to move you and allow the emotion
of of this love that's so tangible that
feels so good to be what it is and that
be good and right and okay
um after sometimes resisting and wanting
to like
maybe we're getting too emotional I mean
I definitely walked under a hoopa at one
time and married Jesus under a hoopa
that was a real thing that I did
so I mean the pendulum's really gone you
know far both ways but
sorry Jesse pull it together now I need
you to lead this song
um but Jesse is gonna lead us in a song
um it's called set a fire so I just
invite you guys to maybe if you're not
someone who would normally naturally
feel at home opening your hands maybe
try that and just experiment like what
does it feel like to allow my body and
my heart to sink into this moment to be
present here
um and and maybe that feels too much you
know but I just want to invite you to
maybe step one one toe further than you
normally would
um in a worship setting and and that
takes courage and I just want to say
like name that you know like yes
sometimes that's uncomfortable but this
is a safe space and I believe that Jesus
will meet you wherever you're at and
whatever you feel comfortable with so
there will not be a grade at the end I
won't call anyone out for a standing
still so gotten pretty used to you guys
over the last several years you're the
most introverted worshipers I've ever
ever known
so I was sitting next to Brittany back
there when Brett was talking about it
and I'm like everyone listen preach
preach somebody raise their hand
no okay I'm done now really we're gonna
do this song
and and just enter in however you feel
comfortable
[Music]
there's no place I would rather be it's
no place I would rather be there's no
place I would rather be
Here In Your Love Here In Your Love No
Place I would rather be
no place I would rather be there's no
place I would rather be
[Music]
there's no place I would rather be
no place
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no place I would rather be
there's no place
me
there's no place I would rather be
there's no place
[Music]
set a fire down in my soul that I can't
contain but I can't control
[Music]
foreign
to continue
[Music]
place I would rather be than Here In
Your Love here in your life there's no
place I would rather be snow
[Music]
ing
is
[Music]
thank you Brett and thank you Mindy and
the rest of the worship team for leading
us tonight and thank you to all of you
who took the time out came today
especially if you're new
we all know how hard it is to kind of
walk into church and go into an
unfamiliar Place we've all been there so
we appreciate you being here and we hope
that you feel welcome and loved
um
I wanted to point out that again if you
are new those little cards I spoke about
before if you can fill one of those out
in the back in the foyer we won't
bombard you with anything we just want
to know if you have a prayer request or
if you want to get more information
about us and we want to get more
information about you as well
I do want to do a quick announcement
reminder just in case I saw some people
walking in as I was doing announcements
so I'm going to run through that really
quickly remember no service next week
we'll see you in two weeks
um we have the pride booth sign up if
you would like to be a part of that it's
in two weeks it's on Saturday June 3rd
in Dallas we would love to have you be a
part of that with us and then Senior
Sunday is June 4th as well so if you
have a senior or a graduate and haven't
let us know please do so that we so we
can recognize and honor them
um
here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive christ-centered
community we want to touch lives and the
generosity that you all have is a key
component in that mission and in us
doing so so if you're willing to join us
in this we want to invite you to go to
the table TX
thetabletexas.org or go to that box with
the little slips on the table so that
you can support us financially in the
work that we do here
the last thing I want to do is uh send
you out with a benediction
kind of like what Brett was saying with
the Liturgy and that and this
benediction is really special to me I
love hearing it every week and I hope
that you all do the same so you're all
standing so you can stand in a posture
of receiving whatever you're comfortable
with but I'll send this out with this
you are a child of God you are a child
of God
this is true on your best day and it is
especially true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
the way that you are and go filled with
God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of love compassion and Grace to
everyone that you come in contact with
this week
hope you'll have a great evening and we
will see you in two weeks good night
[Music]
together
I want more of you God
set a fire down in my soul
[Music]
I want